[Music]
welcome back
okay so we have been deep into the
wilderness of complex functions and
complex variables derivatives and
integrals
koshi gorsa koshi integral formula and
we are just about out of this wilderness
there is one more lecture so i believe i
have timed this so that this is the 13th
lecture in this series on complex
analysis
this should cover about a two-week
course
and i've kind of saved one of the most
interesting applications for last with
all of the tools that we've learned
throughout these two weeks throughout
these 12 prior lectures we are now able
to solve for things like the inverse
laplace transform
which
involves
a pretty gnarly integral in the complex
plane okay so i'm not going to sugar
coat it this is not going to be the
easiest lecture you've ever seen in
complex analysis but it's very very
useful very very important
and it's going to show you how how to
solve for these super important inverse
laplace transforms and i'm going to try
to guide you through
the high level steps that matter why we
are making the choices we're making how
these things work together but i'm also
going to show you the nitty-gritty
details okay so this is going to be a
little bit like going to the gym or
eating your broccoli it's going to make
you stronger
good thing we love
our broccoli and our kale
so
i like to ask my students you know why
do we care about the laplace transform
in the first place maybe i'll maybe i'll
just uh write down the inverse laplace
transform and then we will talk about it
a little bit
so the uh the laplace transform takes a
time domain function and maps it into a
kind of generalized frequency domain
function
so it's kind of a generalization of the
fourier transform for a certain class of
problems
and to get back from that frequency
domain back to the time domain i need to
take the inverse laplace transform which
we call l inverse
of some function f hat which is a
function of that complex variable or
frequency domain variable s my laplace
variable
and this is usually defined as 1 over 2
pi i it's a super hairy integral i'm
going to write it out 1 over 2 pi i
integral of
gamma minus i infinity to gamma plus i
infinity i'll tell you what this means
in a minute
of my frequency domain function f hat
times e to the
s
t
d
s
and this is the definition when i put
that triangle up there you know that
i've kind of just uh
pulled this out of my hat
this is the definition of the inverse
laplace transform so again if i have a
time domain function i laplace transform
it to get a frequency domain function
and to get back to the time domain maybe
maybe i take my ordinary differential
equation
and i laplace transform it to make it
easier to solve and i get my transfer
function and my solution then i inverse
laplace transform to get my solution as
a function of time
this is the inverse laplace transform
function
and specifically there are some
conditions on this so this gamma here
this is an integral in the complex plane
you see this goes from minus i infinity
to i
infinity plus a gamma
gamma is chosen
gamma is chosen to be greater than the
real part
of
all
the poles
f hat so poles are just things like one
over s minus five there will be a pole
at s equals five where it's not analytic
that function's not analytic and i need
gamma to be bigger than the real part of
every pole of this function and i'll
draw you a picture in a minute but this
is a condition
uh we also assume that t
uh is strictly non-negative t is greater
than or equal to zero so this works for
for positive time uh into the future
uh so i'm going to show you how to
compute this integral using things like
cauchy integral formula and the ml bound
and things like that
but just kind of philosophically i'll
give you a little bit of a recap of why
we care about the laplace transform
we use the laplace transform all the
time when we're solving ordinary and
partial differential equations
specifically
you know partial differential equations
that are parabolic like the heat
equation where you know you can solve
for them forward in time but not
backward in time those are going to be
very amenable to using the the laplace
transform for solution
we also use this all the time in
differential equations to transform
differential equations into algebraic
equations that are easier to solve kind
of with high school math and then you
inverse laplace transform those to get
the solutions back in time
also very useful in control theory if
you have input output systems you
laplace transform both sides
uh the outputs of the system and the
inputs of the system and if you take
that ratio that's the transfer function
that tells you if i give a sinusoidal
input what happens to the output of the
system very useful for control systems
and probably one of the most interesting
and useful uh
functions that we might want to inverse
laplace transform so usually if you if
you open up an engineering math book
almost all of them have a big table in
either the front or the back cover of
all of the forward and inverse laplace
transform pairs
and oftentimes you just are told to
memorize these and expected to memorize
them
and i mean that's okay you can remember
what these things are but i want to show
you how to actually derive from scratch
what the inverse laplace transform is
so one of the most inverse important
inverse
laplace transforms we care about so a
specific example
um example
is the function f hat of s equals 1 over
s
minus a where a is often a real number a
equals two or four or negative one okay
um this is a
laplace transform function a frequency
domain function a transfer function that
comes up all the time in differential
equations this is in fact the uh
transfer function
for the simplest differential equation
x dot equals a x
okay and so for example if i laplace
transform this uh differential equation
i get you know the laplace transform of
x dot
equals uh s
x
technically it's s
sorry this is x hat it's s x um you know
minus my initial condition x at time
zero but i'm gonna neglect that
and so if i if i say the laplace
transform of the left-hand side is s x
the laplace transform of the right-hand
side is
a
x hat and if i collect all of my x hats
on one side then i get x
hat
equals so this would be s minus a times
x hat equals
i need that initial condition
let me do this sorry
minus x naught
and that whole thing equals
a times x hat
this is actually the laplace transform
of of x dot you should be catching me on
this you should be
yelling into your monitors so the
laplace transform of the left-hand side
is s
the laplace variable times x-hat the
laplace transform of x minus my initial
condition and that equals the laplace
transform of the right hand side which
is a x hat and now if i collect all of
my x hats i get
s
minus a x hat
equals x naught
and so i can rewrite that as x naught
over s minus a
so this transfer function one over s
minus a comes up all the time it's this
it's the the transfer function for the
simplest differential equation with
initial condition x not equals one okay
that's that's what this transfer
function is
and i want to now that i've transformed
my solution
um so to find this transfer function now
what i want to do is i want to inverse
laplace transform to get x as a function
of t the solution of my differential
equation
so i would inverse
i inverse laplace transform kind of
l negative 1
to get x of t this was in the laplace
variable this is x hat as a function of
s
here i inverse laplace transform this
now to get x as a function of t which
again from differential equations we
know that the solution is just x not
e to the a
t so we know that this is the answer
and in principle that means that we know
that the inverse laplace transform
of 1 over s minus a is equal to e
to the a t
but i want to show you how to actually
solve this inverse laplace transform
using this integral formula in the
complex plane because not all
differential equations that we come up
against are going to be as easy to solve
like i just wrote down the solution of
this differential equation off the top
of my head we know the solution of
linear differential equations
uh x dot equals ax are e to the a t
times the initial condition
so i didn't technically need a laplace
transform an inverse laplace transform
but lots of times there will be uh
differential equations that are hairy
enough and gnarly enough that i really
will want to use the laplace transform
and inverse laplace transform to f to
find the solution so that's what i'm
going to do i'm going to derive today
for you using everything you learned
from complex function theory i'm going
to derive that the inverse laplace
transform of this transfer function this
very important transfer function is e to
the a t and we're going to do that using
integrals in the complex plane
that's what we're doing today
good
and i'm going to start by cooking up a
really big gnarly contour integral for
us to do this uh inverse laplace
transform okay
um so i'm trying to think of where i'm
going to write this down i'm just going
to erase this and then
i'll probably fast forward
okay good
so i'm going to write down this specific
inverse laplace transform integral for
this specific transfer function that
we're going to walk through today
and then we're going to make an attack
plan for how to actually solve this in
the complex plane so the specific
integral we're going to solve
is the inverse laplace transform of 1
over s minus a
and so i'm going to plug in 1 over s
minus a for my function f hat that's my
function f hat
so this is going to equal
1 over 2 pi i integral of gamma minus i
infinity to gamma plus i infinity
of my function
1 over s minus a
times e to the st
e to the st
over 1
over s minus a
and i integrate with respect to the
laplace variable ds so this is the
integral i'm going to be trying to solve
okay
and what's kind of cool about this is
that this looks right out of the gate
like exactly the kind of thing i would
want to use the cauchy integral formula
for okay this is kind of a the poster
child for solving an integral with the
cauchy integral formula because i have
an so s is a complex variable here s is
kind of my z variable
and so this is an analytic function in
the numerator this is an analytic
function
divided by s minus a a kind of a
transfer function with a simple pole at
s equals a so this is exactly what we
want to solve using uh the cauchy
integral formula and so i'm going to
write down a couple of a couple of i'm
basically going to draw the contour
integral that i want to solve and then
we're going to make an attack plan for
how to do this using everything i've
told you about the complex plane
so
[Music]
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
draw in
the complex plane here okay so this is
the complex plane
we have
this pole at s equals a and so i'm just
going to choose arbitrarily a place to
drop down my pole we're going to say
that this is where my pole
a is i'm going to just for now say it's
real valued it doesn't have to be real
valued i'm just going to say it's real
valued and positive so it's an unstable
pole and i'm going to inverse laplace
transform uh that system
so one of the the kind of technical
details of the laplace transform and you
can go back to my video on the laplace
transform to see
is that when you do this integral you
need this gamma
to be to the right it has to have a real
part that's bigger
than the real part of this pole a
in this transfer function so that line
gamma so essentially this integral
is along this big vertical contour
integral
that is offset from the from from the
imaginary axis by gamma so this is kind
of um you know gamma plus i
omega or something like that and this is
the integral that i want i want this big
integral here that's what i've written
down here
and so the strategy that we're going to
take
is that we are going to
essentially create a closed contour
around this pole because we know how to
solve integrals of closed contours of an
analytic function divided by a simple
pole
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
connect
like this i'm going to have a kind of
contour i'm going to call this c plus
and i'm going to have this contour i'm
going to call c minus
and then i'm going to draw a big circle
so this is the classic integral that
people use to solve this problem there's
other ways of doing it but this is kind
of the classic one because it's the
easiest approach
where now i would draw a big radius
circle here cr
okay and if i take the integral i want
let's call this just uh c
i the integral i want you know c one
if i take c one plus c plus plus c r
plus c minus this closed contour
[Music]
we know that we can compute that closed
contour by the cauchy integral formula
it's going to be a simple expression
and if i took the limit as the radius
goes to infinity if i blew this up so
that the radius goes to infinity
then this portion of that contour is the
thing i want it goes from gamma minus i
infinity to gamma plus i infinity
and so so that that's how we're going to
approach this problem let me annotate
this a little bit this is literally um
this here
has a radius r okay
this point here is gamma plus ir this
point here is gamma minus ir
and what we're going to do i'll just
write out the integral we're going to
solve
we're going to say
this is called a bromwich integral by
the way a bromwich
brom
witch
integral not to be confused with the
brood witch integral
the brood witch i don't know if any of
you remember this the brood witch
is one of the tastiest but most evil
sandwiches known to humankind made with
wheat harvested from hell's half acre
mayonnaise made from the eggs of a
deranged chicken
this is why i actually wanted this to be
the 13th lecture
that's not the this is not the brood
which integral this is the bromwich
integral
in texas there is a dairy chain called
brahms that does make sandwiches and
those witches are delicious
this bromwich integral is this full
large closed contour that i'm drawing
this kind of backwards d
we're going to call that c
we're just going to call that c that's
our contour c which is our bromwich
integral
and what we know because of cauchy
integral formula is that we can solve
the integral over this closed contour
this big closed contour for any radius
that encapsulates this for any radius at
all actually for any radius
this closed contour
is going to include that simple pole at
s equals a
and i can use the cauchy integral
formula
to say that the integral of e to the s t
over s minus a d s
around that closed contour
is equal to e
to the a
t
now i'll just refresh what uh this is by
let's let's write this down by
the koshi
integral
formula which i believe uh
was just a couple of lectures ago i
showed you this kosher integral formula
which says if you're integrating an
analytic function in the complex plane
divided by a simple pole s minus a or z
minus a and i'm integrating it in a
closed contour surrounding that pole i
take the analytic function and i
evaluate it at the pole and that's my
answer
and this is times 2 pi i i'm sorry i
should have absolutely this is times 2
pi
i that's what this contour integral
equals
and since i have uh divided by 2 pi i
here those are going to cancel and this
integral is going to equal e to the a t
so
let me just show you i've kind of held
back the last piece
of the logic of the puzzle here and i'm
going to show you that right now
which is the following this contour
integral
maybe i'm just going to do 1 over 2 pi i
out here because this is 1 over 2 pi i
and i'm just going to get rid of this
here
this contour integral
which is easy to solve so this is easy
easy easy to solve using coshy integral
formula we can just write down the
solution of this contour integral around
the whole bromwich contour is e to the a
t
and we know that this is equal to the
integral of the thing i want contour 1
plus the integral of c plus
plus the integral of c minus plus the
integral of c
r
okay so um this big bromwich integral is
the thing i want this integral from
gamma minus i infinity to gamma plus i
infinity
plus this little positive segment plus
the big radius segment plus my little
negative segment so it's four integrals
that i've stitched into one mega
brood which integral
and what i'm going to show you is that
um this
equals you know so let's say in the
in the limit
as r goes to infinity
c1 equals what we want
and i'm going to prove that all three of
these integrals add up to zero that
in the limit as the radius goes to
infinity as i scale this thing
infinitely large so that this c1 becomes
the integral i want
this c plus and the c minus are going to
be zero and the c r is also going to be
zero
so plus zero plus zero plus zero
and what that shows kind of the logic
here is that i can compute this big
bromwich integral easily and it equals e
to the a t
and that in the limit as r goes to
infinity is equal to my integral that i
want
which shows it proves
that this integral that i have here
is going to equal
e to the a t
okay so that's the punch line that is by
far
like that's the the headline here of
this story is that
if i can show that these three integrals
equal zero and the limit as r goes to
infinity we have then proven that this
is the inverse laplace transform of uh
one over s minus a
which i kind of showed you from
differential equations this is in fact
the inverse laplace transform but we are
going to to use complex integrals to
show that
okay so we all that we've used right now
is we've cooked up a complex big gnarly
contour the bromwich contour that i can
break into four pieces
and solving for each of these four
pieces is going to be the hard part
but once i've made this big contour
integral for any radius r i can use
koshi's integral formula very very
easily to show that the the full
bromwich integral equals e to the a t
so if i can show that this segment this
segment and this segment are zero
then this full contour integral that was
easy is just equal to my laplace
transform my inverse laplace transform
integral
good
that's the high level logic
and now for the next i don't know 10 20
minutes i'm going to show you piece by
piece that these three integrals are
equal to zero which then will prove that
this inverse laplace transform equals e
to the a t and then i'll do a quick
recap okay so that's what we're going to
do now
and i'm going to jump right in
[Music]
it turns out
that these ones are kind of easy
so i'm going to show those first we're
going to use the ml bound to show that c
plus and c minus go to zero in the limit
as r goes to infinity
uh okay so integral of
uh
c plus and integral of c minus we're
going to use the m
l bound which is kind of one of the
easiest integral theorems in complex
analysis is very trivial
so the length
of this integral path is always gamma
length is always
gamma regardless of the radius the
radius could be 2 it could be 10 it
could be a million
all that's going to do is change the
the the size of c1 and the size of this
radius kind of scale it up and down
but the length of c plus is always gamma
and the length of c minus is always
gamma so l is uh
the l in the ml bound is always going to
be gamma
and so now what i have to do is i have
to bound
this portion of my integral and i have
to show that this kind of gets smaller
and smaller as my radius increases on
this segment
so
i'm just going to do this for c plus so
for c plus
of e to the s t over s minus a d s
what we have this is equal to the
integral i'm actually going to write out
what this integral equals
it's the integral from gamma
plus ir
to
just i r right we're just moving kind of
in this real direction from gamma plus
ir to ir
uh again of e to the s t over s minus a
d t nope d s sorry d s d s d s
and so um essentially
again i'm going to
use some shorthand notation here to say
that this is an integral
uh from gamma to 0
of e to the x plus i r i'm just saying
that my s variable
my variable s
equals
uh
x plus i r
on this little segment
where x varies from gamma to zero
that's pretty pretty straightforward on
this little segment my complex variable
is x plus ir the imaginary part's always
held constant at i r
and x varies from gamma to zero so i'm
integrating from gamma to zero
of e to the x plus i r
t
divided by
x plus i r
minus a
d x now not d s
d dx
and i'm going to check my notes because
this could be something i would make a
mistake on
but this is correct
and what we're going to show is that
this is you know less than or equal to
some m
l bound so the length of this is gamma
we're going to show that this quantity
is equal to you know is is no greater
than m on that whole path and we're
going to show that that m gets smaller
and smaller as r goes to infinity that's
how ml bounds work and it's really
really kind of elegant and simple
and so m
is the max
of x
between zero and gamma
of
e to the x
plus i r
t
divided by x plus i r minus a kind of
the magnitude of this this is again what
we're doing for ml bounds and i'm going
to claim that this quantity is always
less than or equal to e to the gamma t
over r
now how do i want to do it um
remember this we're going to use this a
bunch in this lecture so i'm just going
to write it down this is e to the
real part plus imaginary part e to the x
t plus i r t
so
if i have
e to the x
t
plus i r t
this is going to equal
e to the x t
times this is from euler's formula you
know cos
rt
plus i sine
and very very important property
this has norm equal to one for any rt
cosine something plus i sine something
the magnitude the length of this vector
is always equal to one so the length of
e to the x t plus i r t is always equal
to the the magnitude of the real part e
to the x t okay this is the magnitude so
the magnitude of this quantity here the
biggest it can be is when x equals gamma
so the maximum magnitude of this
numerator is e to the gamma t
pretty straightforward if that was a
little fast just rewind and go through
it again this is this is a
cornerstone property of complex numbers
that
you know e to the u plus i v
equals e to the u
times cos v plus i sine
v
and this iv no matter what v is it can't
contribute to the length of this vector
um
you know it doesn't contribute at all to
the length of this vector v is
essentially the angle
and the the length of the vector or the
radius is just e to the u the e to the
real part okay and so the max value that
this can uh the the length of this
vector can take is e to the x when x is
gamma okay so that's what we have here
and similarly down here the largest
length that this can have
is
let me see um
x plus i r minus a okay so if i have
um
yeah the biggest this can be is if x
equals a if x equals a then this is zero
and that minus kind of gets cancelled
out
uh and this thing is going to be you
know something which is on the the order
of length of
r let me uh
is that 100 correct
you know if x is between 0 and gamma and
this is a fixed number
then if i make r really really really
really really really big
then this quantity is going to dominate
over those two and so this numerator is
essentially going to be
an r
so what am i trying to say um
yeah the length of this thing sorry i'm
getting i'm mixing myself up let me this
is important though for you to see me
get confused because this is confusing
um
this numerator is always less than or
equal to e to the gamma t good
and in fact it its maximum value is
exactly when x equals gamma and is
exactly e to the gamma t so this should
be for the numerator that's inequality
that's the maximum value
and it's divided by something
and
the max of this thing is attained when
the new when the denominator is the
smallest length it can possibly be
and this thing has its smallest
norm or length
normally it would be r squared plus x
minus a squared
square root and so if x minus a is
non-zero this thing is actually a really
really big radius you know it's a bigger
number it's a bigger length
and so i'm saying that the maximum value
is when this has its smallest norm this
has its smallest value when x equals a
and when x equals a which is in this
interval
then the norm of this is exactly equal
to r
okay so that's again that was a little
bit confusing a little bit fast you
might want to rewind that last two
minutes if you if you think so
so to find the max of this whole length
i'm trying to find the value x where the
numerator is as big as possible and
where the denominator is as small as
possible the biggest the numerator can
get is e to the gamma t when x equals
gamma the smallest the length of the
denominator can get is r when x equals a
so this is the ml bound m
everywhere on
this curve
my function
is has length no no larger than e to the
gamma t over r
and the nice thing about that is that
now
m and l so m
is e to the gamma t over r
l is a constant gamma
so if i take the limit
as r goes to infinity this thing goes to
zero because i'm dividing by infinity
i'm dividing a constant number times a
constant number divided by infinity goes
to zero
that proves that c plus the plus part of
my contour
this integral
equals zero
and the c minus is exactly the same you
don't i'm not going to like do a whole
nother thing just for c minus it's
exactly the same
so both of these plus and minus portions
of the integral equal zero in the limit
as my radius goes to infinity as this
thing gets bigger and bigger
okay so
those two are done
and now
i have to show that this big cr contour
also goes to zero
i'm going to erase my board and that's
what we're going to do next
okay
so now i'm going to solve
the hardest part of this okay so bear
with me
this is never going to be easy
but this is important okay like we just
spent two weeks learning all this
interesting complex function theory and
how to integrate in the complex plane
and this is an actual legitimately
useful and important application here is
to solve the inverse laplace transform
and so i really i really want to get to
to show you so now i'm going to show
that this big radius portion of the
curve goes to zero as my radius goes to
zero so i'm going to show that this
equals zero
this one's going to be a little bit
trickier so ml bounds for integral of cr
ml bounds don't work
uh
at least i've never been able to get it
to work don't work
and so we're going to use some tricks
these are tricks that i must have picked
up somewhere in my education i don't
remember where i got these
uh you will someday forget where you
learned them
but the basic tricks is we're going to
try polar coordinates
and that's why we extended this instead
of just having a big radius coming
directly from uh c1 that's why we had c
plus and c minus to move these over to a
place where we could actually use polar
coordinates so this point
is going to be r
you know e to the i theta so there's
going to be an r cosine theta and an r
sine theta so we're going to say
x equals minus r cosine
theta and we're going to say y equals
our
sine theta
and we're going to do an integral
basically from theta equals
minus pi halves to pi halves something
like that okay we'll we'll see and
you'll have to check that i'm doing the
right bounds of integration
uh and so essentially what we're doing
is you know we're solving for this
portion of the bromwich integral here
where you know theta is going to start
at
and i'm really abusing
abusing polar notation here this is i'm
calling this
minus pi halves because i have a minus r
cosine theta
and i have you know this goes to theta
equals plus pi halves
and it's going counterclockwise
i am pretty sure there's a better way of
integrating from plus pi halves to minus
pi halves with a plus r cosine theta
and maybe i should do that but i'm just
going to stick with my notes and maybe
as an exercise you can try to you know
use the normal polar convention of x
equals plus r cosine theta and change
this to theta equals plus pi halves to
minus pi halves i think you know we're
pretty good at uh changing the
definition of where things start and
what's positive and negative so i think
this will be okay
and so we're again trying to to kind of
show what the properties of these two
terms in this integral are
uh across this contour from theta equals
minus pi halves to pi halves so i'm
going to isolate this and break this up
i have the uh maybe i'll switch colors
to make it a little more interesting so
i have my e to the s t portion i'm going
to look at the norm of that
again the length the norm uh if i have a
if i haven't you know my s t has a real
part let's call that you know x
plus i y
the norm of uh
you know e to the s t the norm of that
is going to equal e to the x it's going
to be the length of e to the real part
so the norm of this is going to be minus
r e to the minus r cosine theta that's
that's going to be the norm of this
thing
so that's uh e to the minus r cos
theta t that's the norm of of the
numerator is this thing here
uh and the norm of s minus a the
denominator here is similarly going to
equal the norm of and i'm just going to
plug everything in here
um
i think it's minus r cos
theta
um
plus i r
sine
theta minus a and i put the minus a here
because i'm going to group these real
valued parts and this complex value part
separately but but the s is the r cosine
and r sine and the a is right here okay
so that's the norm and that norm is
equal to uh this is kind of a mess but
it's the square root
of r cos theta
plus a
quantity squared
plus r sine
theta
quantity squared
the square root of that it's literally
the the norm of this is the real part
squared plus the imaginary part squared
square root that's this
and if i do a little fancy
arithmetic here and i cancel out some
stuff i'm going to get an r cos squared
and an r sine squared those are going to
add up to an r squared so i'm going to
get an r squared i'm going to get a plus
r
cos
theta
plus a squared
okay that's what all of this simplifies
to you can verify that
and i'm going to claim
that this is always greater than or
equal
to r minus a to the norm of r minus a
okay
um
why is that true so this is kind of
[Music]
um
well the norm of r minus a is r
squared plus a squared minus 2
a
r
and this is i'm sorry i missed an a when
i expanded this out this should be 2 r
times a times cosine theta
and yeah so the norm of r minus a is
just r squared plus a squared minus 2ar
so it looks almost identical to this
except that up here this 2 ar is
multiplied by cos theta and cos theta
can never be bigger than 1 so this
expression is always strictly
less than or equal
yeah th this expression here is always
um
i this should be a greater than or equal
i'm sorry
this should be less than or equal
this expression here the length of this
r squared
plus a squared
i'm sorry i'm like uh
it's been a real wilderness of complex
variables
uh this was correct i want you to i want
you to really see
why this is true so i'm gonna derive
this uh i'm gonna i'm gonna show this
again this is this is the hardest
integral so it makes sense that we're
getting a little confused here
we're going to do something kind of like
the ml bound we're finding the norm of
this and the norm of this and i'm going
to use some argument to show that as r
goes to a large number you know the
ratio goes to zero something like that
and so i need an expression for the norm
of s minus a and i've done some math and
i've done a trick and i've done another
trick
and now i am showing that this
expression here is always
bigger than the norm of r minus a the
norm of r minus a is this quantity here
and this is minus 2 a r so this thing is
always you know detracting from the norm
it's making it smaller
[Music]
and unless cosine of theta is exactly
equal to -1
this term
is
detracting less or maybe even adding to
the norm of r minus a so so i want you
to just think about why
this is always bigger than or equal to
this
because of the properties of cosine so
if cosine is negative one then this
equals this but if cosine is anything
you know bigger than negative one you
know
it goes between negative one and plus
one this expression is greater than this
norm here and we're going to use this
property kind of like we use the ml
bound
good
okay so
uh that is very useful
and so what this means is i'm gonna say
so
the integral
of
the integral over cr of e to the st
over s minus a d s
is um let's say that the the norm of
this whole thing
is strictly less than
this integral we're going to now
integrate over thetas because we've gone
to polar coordinates
the um
integral of of the with respect to theta
of this thing
e to the minus r cos
theta t
divided by
uh norm of r minus a
times
and we're integrating from minus pi over
to pi over 2
d theta
and
[Music]
last important thing when we're
integrating in polar coordinates this is
r d theta because we're at a radius r
and so we're going r
times d theta is uh you know every
little segment here d s is r d theta
because we're at a big radius r okay
this is radius r
and uh so now what we're going to try to
do is we're going to try to show that
this thing goes to zero as r goes to
infinity
okay um
and we can also even simplify this more
we can this is an even function this is
an uh an even function and so we can say
that this equals
uh 2r
over r minus a norm
integral from 0 to 2pi sorry
pi pardon my french
pi over 2 laplace was french
of e to the minus r t
cos
theta
d theta
we're integrating with respect to theta
we pulled out the r's this is a really
ugly pi over 2.
and i was able to do this
i was able to do this integral
to say that this this integral from
minus pi over 2 to pi over 2 equals this
because it's an even function so i
picked up this value of 2 it's twice
this half of that even function
okay we're getting really close thank
you for bearing with me
just a little bit farther if this is
just boring you to tears you can skip to
the next chapter mark but i would stay
with me because we're almost there
and so there are a couple of other
tricks we're going to do here
um
basically we're just going to keep doing
tricks until we can force this thing
into a
reasonable reasonable solution so the
last trick is that cos
theta is always greater than or equal to
1 minus 2
theta over pi
on the interval
theta between zero and
pi halves
okay on that interval
and so
e to the minus r
cos theta t
is always less than or equal to e to the
minus r t
times this value here this 1 minus 2
theta over
pi
good
and i could make my minus go in here and
say that that's of course equal to
e to the r t
times 2 pi
over theta 2 theta over pi minus 1.
okay so i've just used uh kind of every
trick at my disposal every trigonometric
trick i have you can again verify that
this is true this is just um
like kind of a basic trigonometric fact
that you should uh verify if you don't
believe me
and so finally this integral here this
uh integral here
we're going to say
is um
this thing here
is less than or equal to 2 r over norm
of r minus a of this integral
which is 2 r over norm of r minus a of
this integral
from 0 to pi halves
of now this expression here e
to the rt
theta
2 theta over pi minus 1
d theta
it's actually strictly less than or
equal to this
and this is something we can actually
solve this is now an integral e to the
theta constant plus a constant d theta
we can actually solve this closed form
so we're basically there
and that equals
2 r over norm of r minus a
pi over 2 r t e to the r
t
2 theta over pi minus 1 this whole thing
evaluated at the bounds of integration
pi over 2 and 0. and if you plug all of
this stuff in here so at this point this
just became a standard integral you do
know how to solve this is the answer
we're going to evaluate it
and that just equals pi
over norm of r minus a
t
one minus e to the minus r
and
e to the r t e to the minus r t as r
goes to infinity this goes to zero so
this whole expression goes to one as r
goes to infinity
and pi over norm of r minus a the norm
of r goes to infinity as r goes to
infinity
so this whole thing goes to zero
as r goes to infinity
whoa
that was a mess okay this is a nightmare
that's why i think of this as the
broodwich inner rule because this is the
most evil integral uh you'd use so many
tricks to get this
uh
this big radius cr to go to zero as r
goes to infinity but it is technically
possible right so we used a bunch we
switched to polar coordinates we derived
these expressions for what these
numerator and denominator are bigger
than or smaller than and then we did
more trig substitutions but eventually
we showed and you'll have to check my
steps like i require you know i expect
my students to actually check these
steps that i did in the middle just to
really convince yourself and kind of go
back and see why i was doing it in the
first place
okay good so that was the tough part now
i am going to summarize everything
so the big summary here is
that i'm trying to solve this inverse
laplace transform integral because
that's super duper useful in
differential equations both ordinary and
partial
in control theory and in tons of other
fields of engineering is to be able to
laplace transform and inverse laplace
transform
and specifically if i want to inverse
laplace transform something like this
function one over s minus a which comes
up all the time in linear differential
equations
i essentially need to
solve for this very very large vertical
integral in the complex plane the
integral from gamma minus i infinity to
gamma plus i infinity
and so what i do instead is i create a
large closed contour called the bromwich
integral that has the integral i want c1
plus three other segments that i don't
want
but i close this loop around that pole
so that i can use koshi's integral
formula because i can solve i can
integrate this closed contour integral
around c
of my function i'm trying to inverse
laplace transform easily using cauchy
integral formula it's essentially
trivial because this is an analytic
function and there's a it's divided by a
simple pole at s equals a
then the closed contour integral of
everything equals e to the a t
and that's the sum of the integral i
want plus this
this little segment
plus
this little minus segment plus this big
radius contour here
and so if i can show that in the limit
as r goes to infinity that these three
terms go to zero
and in the limit as r goes to infinity
this segment becomes the integral i want
so if i can show that these three go to
zero
then the integral i want equals e to the
a t
and we showed it took i guess 25 30
minutes that these three integrals equal
zero in the limit as r goes to infinity
so therefore we have shown that the
integral we want the laplace the inverse
laplace transform by koshi integral
formula and some heinous math
is equal to this e to the a t
so that's super duper cool and i think
now you are armed with some of the most
powerful tools
in mathematics you know how to integrate
in the complex plane you know how to
differentiate in the complex plane and
now you can solve these are some of the
nastiest integrals out there
if you can solve these you can solve
anything all right i'm really proud of
you all for sticking with me
through you know 50 minutes of complex
integrals bromwich integrals this is the
real deal
i'll see you next time thank you